um
this part
let us let us uh put her on a grid
okay
you see the orientation of her spine
and you know
[Music]
that at the end of ikyoura
you want her to not be turtle
you see there's two ways of doing it
there's the ego tripartite way
where you're gonna go forward
see that
i'll do that part so in other words i'm
gonna take her on the vector her spine
is currently on
okay
and you're here
you go like that okay
ready
second way
is
let's orient ourselves how we work
before
bring back
okay
there it is
i'm not going to lengthen her in the
obvious way
on the same vector her spine is
i'm going to turn her relax
leave it out
i'm going to turn her
this way
she's not turtle
come back
and that is your aikido geometry
some of you will go here
is she
is she uh
prone no
and now you go like this
so it's in
between
but in between is still incorrect
okay
so
and we do this
you keep turning how far should you turn
as far as it needs for her to
lose the turtle position
you can't usually what happens is that
you uh
go this is my style
is that it's not your style okay
it's uh
around
there
okay
and then through that
you add
the
final form requirement
which is i have to bring it around
and end up
with the hand head level
and my knee at her armpit
and my wrist and my other knee at her
wrist
okay this is where we land
and that's going to tell you
what's too far
what's not far enough still turtle and
now along the vector the spine is
already on what is too far
is
when the hand comes back down
around
you see
it's supposed to be here so when you
have to make this correction
we did the technical
got it
okay
okay what i'm trying to tell you
is that it ends you see
it it all stops at once
if i'm doing it right it's not just
a last portrait
that deems that i did the technique
right
it's how i got there
and when i got there
okay so right now as you do
those variations
where you go this way
and you give yourself that correction
you want to understand that is incorrect
failure
just as wrong
as
your teacher is going to go what the
do you get but that is as much deviation
okay
likewise
the same way as i push her straight
there's no way to get there but to do it
wrong
if you come around
and you're going to do half
spiral instead of measure because that's
all the turn i can get
do you see and now you hide the
incapability of your ura
by now doing
wrong again
likewise
coming around
and again the incapability of my root up
i did more than last time
but
turned after do you see
wrong again
or
i lose the hat
you see
because i i'm focusing on too much
my mind got fettered and you come here
and now you go
all this
do you get it wrong again
okay
it's n is
like a shortcut once you're not sitting
here going
okay try it again